how do you know if a writer is capable
of writing at a professional level
if they move you emotionally because
it's about emotions
it's about making people feel something
and there's writers that could write
to the forum perfectly and you read it
it's fine
but it doesn't make you feel anything
in the same way like i listen to music
almost like a drug like i'll listen to
music that will get me hyped i'll get
listen to music that will mellow me like
it moves you
you could use uh this you know
the audio experience to change your
state of mind
movies in my opinion could do the same
way there's movies that will that get
you hyped and disturbed
movies that will like make you kind of
like have comfort food
they have qualities to them and
i think that the key to know if a writer
is somebody that you want to work with
is you are
being affected it's changing your state
of mind
in a in a powerful way and
if it's just the script and you read it
and it's totally
derivative you just feel like it's like
a bad cover band
like who knows who wants to watch the
the cover band you want to watch
kiss play you know or whatever it is you
want to see the ideally you want to see
the
the purest form of that vision
and and when i speak to the sense of a
cover band is
you want somebody's authentic voice and
that's what you're getting you want the
purest
version of who they are and
that's gonna get you really
into their work if those hooks get in
you because you're feeling
someone is very unique as speaking to
you through the work
and changing your emotional you know
levels you know and that's what art does
it affects you
so i think for me to gauge whether or
not someone's professional
is like am i getting excited am i
getting scared am i
disturbed like like is it is it
influencing me
and if it's not maybe i don't like the
genre or whatever or the tone that's
fine
or maybe the writer needs to do another
few rewrites to really
refine you know their vision
so are there are there writers that are
versions of cover bands i mean sometimes
i've heard some amazing cover bands by
the way but
yes sometimes it's it's a watered-down
version of
your favorite artist but are there are
there cover band writers
i don't know if there's exactly like i
would say purely a cover band writer and
like there are awesome cover bands like
don't get me wrong i mean there's some
that really have their own
you know take on something or kind of
almost supernaturally
capture the essence of
a musician that you love which is also
really cool i'm just saying that you
know maybe there's like a version
of a cover band that feels kind of hacky
you know that doesn't hit all the beats
doesn't have that
you know excitement that intangible
quality that made you fall in love
with a band they're they're good enough
right and you're like
okay i've seen that before it's so why
am i seeing it like this it feels like
the
the watered-down version that's
different there are
writers that are very nostalgic and they
in a lot of ways they sample openly
certain qualities that you might like
from a movie
from the 80s and but they make it their
own
you know they're not just they're not
like stealing from anything
they're extracting the essence of it and
then you're seeing something uh
you're seeing a point of view so i guess
that's what i would say is
the point of view maybe not a point of
view on
let's say like this is the point of view
on the theme that's a universal theme
and they talk about it
it could be a point of view on a genre
so maybe they're talking about slashers
but it's a really interesting hot take
it's
the same way you think of like a great
film critic could talk about a movie and
really make you think about it and
really feel something different about
the movie
a writer that could have these
perspectives i wouldn't call a cover
band i would say they're offering
insight into storytelling and maybe in a
meta quality or something that's really
fascinating
i'm talking about what i'm talking about
here is somebody is uninspired
that is not offering anything new to the
intellectually or maybe emotionally then
it's just why do we need another x
okay so it's like a cover band if you
said kiss so
it's like you've gone to a bar and
they're playing detroit rock city but
it's like
slow and it's it's kind of distorted
and you're like almost but not quite
like oh this almost hurts my ears
so it's the same thing a writer's trying
to emulate let's say jk rowling and
they're trying but it's it's like no i
see what they're trying to do
and they're speed they're trying to
emulate her voice they're emulating it
without
offering a new perspective you know
because there are
because in a lot of ways like you know
storing certain creators or almost like
i was saying like critics
is they're using their work to almost be
uh you know to comment on
a type of character or type of genre and
that actually to me is actually really
interesting
mine's like the my criticism of a
certain
type of writer is when they're not
bringing anything new to the table
their perspective is is not defined
and then they're just recycling and it
just and you really don't get anything
out of it so yeah that's that's what i'm
talking about so yeah like there's
amazing cover bands i'm talking about
the cover band where you're like
why don't i just watch the actual van
like that's the one not someone that
goes oh my god i thought i was there
or you know like who am i who's on stage
or wow this
crazy subversion of the song like the
pixies
have had like a million covers of their
big song you know where's my mind but
the good coverage really take you
somewhere different okay so it kind of
like
almost like prog rock of something that
wasn't meant to be that way
or it captures it beautifully like i'm
open to those things but
i'm talking about the end of the day the
type of script that when i'm done
reading i don't get anything emotionally
or intellectually
new from my baseline experience how does
the writer know that they are the
original writer
that's their voice they have to share
their perspective in the same way as a
manager
i have to be honest to myself you know
what
you know material gets me you know into
the game
and gets me you know ready to like go
out and start selling and
pushing projects is i have to believe in
it you know
has to be real to me in a lot of ways it
has to be real to them
you know when you see a lot of
filmmakers starting out
like in the early stages like somebody
might come out of film school
and they may look to a director that
they love
and almost do their own version of a
cover band because
they're just trying to learn the
technology
they're learning the the craft but then
as they
mature they advance beyond that and then
they start cultivating a voice
they may have certain genetic you know
quality
of the genetics of their favorite
filmmakers but it's also
a new statement they're making in the
space that is only
theirs because i think we can all
think that we're original you know like
but if i let's say i'm always reading
joyce carol oates novels
i'm going to probably allow that to seep
into my
writing style and maybe not even be
aware of it so how do i know
is it from feedback from outside sources
is that the only way we really know if
we're being authentic
i think that like it's fine if somebody
goes i'm a alpha hitchcock super fan
and that's going to inspire my work
but it's where we go from there like i
think some people
you know could look at you know the
amount of filmmakers that that one you
know auteur
just influence and there's just so many
countless you know
students of this director but it's what
they do with it
why is it interesting you know and the
only way to know how your work resonates
is have people read it
so like maybe somebody
could write something that's in the the
vein of
another creator but what
they end up making is still impactful
so you're measuring impact not some type
of purity test of originality
is you give someone your script they get
moved emotionally
and intellectually that's that's what
the goal is
so yeah i don't want to make it so like
i'm evaluating
does it have to be perfectly original or
whatever that means i don't know if they
even means anything
i'm talking about what are do people
love the experience does it experience
is it is it memorable
uh that's what matters i don't want to
get into like that director sampled this
and that
like to me it's like i don't care i like
i like collage artists
i like artists that take things i like
uh producers that produce music
and they sample like other artists and
they make something
interesting but they have to make
something interesting i think that's
what i'm evaluating is
the experiential quality not whether or
not
they you know were clearly inspired by
somebody else that's not
the metric do you have an example of
maybe a film you watched in college
where it just
it changed you somehow
for better or worse i don't think like
any movie like it's like a that i was
actually changed but i do
see i do see movies that i just get
excited by
like and i don't know if there was like
some you know
spiritual experience where i was like
whoa everything's changed but
i do really love um
sure movies by john waters or tarantino
or like takeshi katano like i see what
they could do
or you know elaine may like there's
people making things and they you know
i don't know how they did that it just i
blew my mind i mean it's almost like if
you're like
you know a food critic and you go to
some restaurant and you bite into
something and you're like whoa
what just happened here you know like
there's something like
something's going on i can't put a
finger on it but it's really working
so i don't think there's this one thing
i think it's more of like
a mix of a lot of different experiences
but
i think i think when you're done with it
you're like i want to watch every movie
they made
like i want to watch whatever they have
next or
if they're not live i just want to move
through their entire like
library and check out what they have
going on so to me that that's how i feel
it's just
you get excited it's excitement that's
what we're measuring or not it's not
it's not like we pull out a measuring
stick and we go we're measuring the
perfect exact
thing it's like he's like you know when
you say holy
that is great and it's so good you want
to tell everybody about
it that's how you know it matters is
that you want to share it with somebody
that's way
i think it's kind of like when you want
to push a movie on somebody else
it's not just like casually talk about a
movie like there's a movie um
called pill flowers a yakuza crime film
old black and white film
it's so good i have influenced like five
of my friends to watch it
so when you're getting other people to
get into whatever you're into that's how
you know it worked
obviously but like that's how i know
that a film is
deeply resonated is that i'm now
representing the movie
as a super fan does it have subtitles
yes oh so it's a japanese film
what year is it from not sure it was
like something that like i found and
then i just
started pushing to people who i think
would like it so then i start like
recommending it and telling everyone i
know about it so
that's how i look at it is that i don't
have one special experience
but i just know the physic the actual
events that take place
in my mind when i see a movie like that
or i see or specifically i could point
to a filmmaker where i'm like that
person's doing something
really exciting and then i just you know
for the rest of my life i'm
i'm pushing that filmmaker or their
movie
on anyone in the airshot
you